200 km de lignes 72 nouvelle gare voilà
en chiffres le projet du Grand Paris
Express une boucle ferroviaire autour de
Paris mais le Grand Paris Express dans
son intégralité verra-t-il le jour le
Premier ministre Jean-Marc Ayraud doit
arbitrer d'ici le 15 février déjà un
rapport suscite la colère des lieux
yvelin des signés Jean-Marc aux Annet
dans ce rapport il préconise que la
ligne verte celle concernant le
département et le développement du
plateau de sa clé pourrait être
repoussée en 2030 impossible 10 de
légions le président du conseil général
le MP Alain Schmitt le président de la
Chambre de commerce Gérard bachelier et
le député maire de Versailles françois
de Mazières ils ont adressé un courrier
au Premier ministre
nous attirons son attention sur l'absolu
nécessité de commencer la ligne verte or
dans le rapport aux années si la ligne
verte n'est pas abandonnée c'est tout
comme c'est d'autant plus aberrant que
l'on du plateau de Saclay doit démarrer
tant sur le territoire aigle noir que
sur le territoire de l'Essonne et que
cette ligne verte qui a été portée
notamment par Valérie Pécresse et qui a
été rattaché aux lignes rouges du Grand
Paris est essentiel pour le
développement de ce de ce territoire
dans leur courrier les signataires
proposent un métro léger en surface
moins onéreux que la proposition de
ligne souterraine pour rappel le Grand
Paris Express comprend en quatre lignes
autour de la capitale rouge pour le Nord
orange pour l'Est bleu pour le sud et
donc verte pour l'Ouest cette dernière
ligne pourrait relier à terme 50 ans en
Yvelines à l'aéroport d'Orly en passant
par la gare TGV de Massy permettant
ainsi à Versailles d'être relié en 35
minutes à l'aéroport international